the board of Crisis was front of mind
for Governors across the country and
joining me now is Colorado governor
Jared Polis it's wonderful to have you
last week you were in Washington DC a
lot all the governors were gathered
there talking to the administrator
talking amongst each other but also
talking to the administration about what
you need was there a bipartisan
consensus asking the Biden
Administration to do more on immigration
well absolutely and it starts with of
course border security 80
000 fentanyl deaths last year in America
and by the way most of that crosses at
border crossings trucks and cars with
the technology we have with dogs we can
significantly reduce that we need
Congress to step up and fund that and of
course the broader security border
security as well we also need to make
sure that we process Asylum claims
quicker people that are caught up here
for a year a year and a half in
paperwork until they can work and earn a
living frankly they're a burden we have
to put them up they become an asset the
minute they get that work permission and
work hard we need workers in States like
Colorado and across the country we have
two job openings for every unemployed
person right now okay so then what what
did you hear back from the
administration on that
well as you know if it's about border
security the reason that President Trump
and President Biden haven't been able to
secure the border is it takes Congress
to step up and fund it no president has
the power of the purse the ability to
spend money Congress needs to step up in
a bipartisan way and actually fund
border security I am confident that both
this President the last president
support border security ran on border
security but it's always been treated by
an afterthought and in these very
important discussions about raising the
debt ceiling where they're making cuts
and there are areas that need to make
Cuts they need to make sure that not
only is border security not an area they
make a cut but they actually have the
right investment to reduce the flow of
Fentanyl and reduce the flow of people
illegally have you seen a fentanyl
problem there in Colorado
yeah sadly Colorado is no exception to
these trends that are occurring
nationally the vast majority enters at
checkpoints on our Southern border
meaning trucks and cars it's more
controllable if it was through the open
it's an industrial operation and it's
killing people and we have a
multi-pronged approach including
Behavioral Health Outreach education
also tougher criminal penalties to go
after dealers and people with pill
presses we were one of the first states
to add a felony charge for possession of
a pill press which are used to mix
fentanyl with other drugs a lot of
people inadvertently consume Fentanyl
and die so it's all hands on deck across
the country on this war on fentanyl
let's talk about education for a moment
I went to Denver public schools K
through fifth grade and then we moved
out to the suburbs in Parker Colorado
and
I did a story yesterday about Baltimore
has terrible math scores for their
children there in that City the Colorado
report card's not great either fourth
grade at or above proficient and reading
and math is only 38 in 2022 and that's a
decrease and in math 36 percent again a
decrease that's for the fourth graders
the eighth grades have a similar
situation
are you alarmed concerned and do you
think that school choice might be
something that can help here
you're one of our proud Ponderosa High
School alumni and we'll we'll never
forget that
um one of the things we're looking at
you know there's a very simple
correlation of time on task and learning
and so we are working on after school
math tutoring like the rest of the
country Colorado math scores drop we're
still above average compared to the rest
of the country but we we want to help
fund through the state across the state
charter schools public schools every
school after school math tutoring for
kids who need it look there's great
examples of choice and innovation in our
state we're about 15 and a half percent
of our kids go to Charter Schools but
just like any model there's good Charter
Schools there's charter schools that
don't perform as well there's good
district-run schools there's District
run schools that don't perform as well
but the fact that we have these choices
Empower parents to make the best
decision for their child the other thing
you're thinking about doing is you want
to possibly eliminate the Colorado State
income tax a quick final word on that
we've had two reductions that have been
voter approved since I've been Governor
we reduced the income tax from 4.63 to
4.4 percent two different reductions
we're doing our best to use the surplus
funds that we have uh to try to get the
legislature to do another reduction
along with other refund mechanisms I
think we shouldn't penalize success we
should incentivize success so we should
find things that are what we call an
economics negative externalities things
that we don't like as a society that
should have effectively taxes or fees
not something like income which we want
everybody to make income it's a great
thing for everybody you might have a lot
of New Yorkers head into Colorado I
don't know if how you feel about that
we welcome we welcome them they just
need to be a little bit more easy going
than they are in the streets of New York
City all right Governor Jared Polis
thanks for joining us this morning
I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and
I'm Ainsley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis